[Música]
y pasamos a hablar entonces de economía
en directo américa de france24 ya está
lista en el estudio nuestra periodista
daniela blandón danny pues empezamos a
hablar también de la economía en este
segundo bloque en el mercado petrolero
se comienza a hacer entonces las cuentas
sin russian y creo que si raúl porque la
agencia internacional de energía que
tiene a 31 países miembros puede salir
todo el riesgo de que se produzca lo que
llamó la mayor crisis de oferta de
petróleo en décadas ante la posibilidad
esto de que desaparezca del mercado una
parte importante de la producción rusa
específicamente cree que en abril
podrían salir del mercado unos 3
millones de barriles de rusia por día
esto es casi la mitad de los 8 millones
que exporta como consecuencia de las
sanciones de occidente y es que rusia es
un importante jugador mundial porque sus
exportaciones suplen alrededor del 8 por
ciento de la demanda mundial peligro dan
y entonces de que falte el petróleo en
el mundo es justamente ese el verdadero
temor de la agencia internacional de
energía más aún cuando la opep que es el
gremio de países exportadores advierte
que tienen serias dificultades para
aumentar su oferta de petróleo y para
recuperar los niveles que tenían desde
la pandemia también dice que si faltara
suministro ruso no tendrían como reponer
lo rápidamente y también se enfrenta hoy
ese país como si fuera poco a un pago
clave no rusia hagan y claro casi tiene
dos vencimientos de deuda
específicamente de intereses de bonos
por 117 millones de dólares con 30 días
de gracia si no nos paga entraría en su
primer default desde
1917 el fondo monetario internacional no
cree que rusia pueda pagar pero el
ministerio de finanzas dice que si puede
hacerlo pero lo haría en rublos porque
las sanciones occidentales le impiden
pagar en dólares el mercado en todo caso
cree que si no entrega dólares que fue
lo que le prestaron pues estaría
incumpliendo y estos vencimientos son
apenas los primeros de varios que le
esperan en marzo por un total de 615
millones de dólares
bueno dan y entonces qué más puede pasar
si no paga por ejemplo pues mire la
economía se vería seriamente afectada
raúl porque desde el comienzo de lo que
moscú llama la operación militar
especial en ucrania ya sabemos que
muchas empresas occidentales han
abandonado el país o suspendido sus
operaciones y se han impuesto amplias
sanciones pues tenemos algunas opiniones
de ciudadanos
la situación es un callejón sin salida
nada se puede resolver ahora sin un
cambio de dirección
todos los pequeños ahorros que tengo
están en una cuenta de ahorros confían
que todo saldrá bien aquí también
embelesado tome algunas medidas desde el
principio aumente mis gastos adelante la
compra de algunos dispositivos pero no
tome ninguna medida drástica durante
algún tiempo estar aguantando la
situación actual pero después debes
buscar algunas formas de resolverlo
bueno y dejamos a un lado entonces la
guerra en ucrania por un momento daniela
para hablar de más noticias económicas
pero de nuestra región américa y el
caribe claro que así comenzamos por su
país venezuela que entra este miércoles
en vigencia un acuerdo en un aumento del
salario mínimo que pasará de lo
equivalente a 1,6 dólares mensuales a
casi 30 dólares mensuales según el
gobierno el primer pago se haría el 30
de este mes con retroactivo también
subirá a 10 dólares por mes el bono de
alimentación que aplica para empleados
más no para pensionados
continuamos a la argentina donde la
inflación sigue acelerándose e impulsada
por los alimentos en apenas un año hasta
febrero los precios de la canasta básica
aumentaron en 52 3% sólo en el último
mes lo hicieron en 47 la tasa más alta
desde marzo de 2021
y cerramos en eeuu en donde el
presidente joe biden retiró la polémica
candidatura de serra pluma a la junta de
gobernadores de la reserva federal como
supervisora de la banca el partido
republicano la acusaba de tener
conflictos de interés
y pasamos entonces a hablar danny de los
indicadores pues hablando de la fed raúl
nos quedamos ahí porque los mercados
están muy pendientes de las decisiones
que tomen este miércoles después de su
junta directiva a europa tiene amplias
ganancias tras la espera sobre esta
decisión
en asia el principal índice de hong kong
ganó casi un 10% después de que los
líderes chinos prometieron más apoyo
para la desaceleración de la economía y
para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día de hoy las cifras de los
altísimos precios de un carro tesla
ahora los precios de estos vehículos
subieron entre el 5 y el 10 por ciento
en todos los modelos en eeuu y algunos
en china este es el segundo aumento en
menos de una semana y la empresa
justifica la decisión en el aumento del
precio de las materias primas y las
dificultades logísticas y es que
productos como el aluminio o el paladio
o el níquel el litio están en máximos
históricos yo me quedé con las ganas
cuando estaba de vacaciones en méxico
había una aplicación de
de transporte que puedes pedir un tesla
y si todavía ese monto y señor no yo no
a mí me tocó uno se otro carrito y
normalito en un test a darle gracias
entonces por toda la información
económica nos vemos mañana con más
economía y por supuesto mañana también
un día más de directo américa aquí en
france 24 espero un noticiero habitual
[Música]